magine and phatu are the only two
northern white rhinos left in the world
they live under 24-hour protection in
the old pajota Conservancy in Kenya and
that's because both females are the last
and only hope of saving the species from
disappearing forever with the help of
science sperm was saved from the last
living northern white rhino male called
Sudan and a few others he became famous
around the world when he featured on a
popular dating app to raise money for an
in-vitro fertilization procedure since
his death the team of international
scientists has been racing against time
to fertilize eggs from the gene and
fatty using pioneering technology and
millions of dollars later on Thursday
they successfully extracted five eggs
from each female the eggs can be frozen
and were immediately flown to a
fertilization lab in Italy and if
everything goes well then the
authorizers will be capable of
fertilizing will be fertilized likely on
a Sunday and then it took about two
weeks to know what do we have some
embryos for health reasons in the gene
and fats who can't give birth so once
the embryos are fertilized
they'll be implanted into a surrogate
southern white rhino instead demand for
rhino horn in traditional Chinese
medicine as well as things like dagger
handles in Yeman
fuelled poaching in the 1970s and 80s
largely wiping out the northern white
rhino population in africa but if a
surrogate southern mother can produce a
baby northern white rhino than these
beautiful creatures that have roamed the
earth for millions of years may avoid
what seemed like certain extinction
pilot Al Jazeera